steal it from him along the wall and get it
down the ice minute 20 left on this ranger
Power Play It's taken away by Curtis Lazar he
accelerates ahead Lazar to the front tried to
put it on but he was tied up by Guston he cut
hard to the net and guson just got a piece of
that puck but it did roll towards shurk and
he was looking for maybe a a break a bounce
comes to there and he's free and he ripped it
lde of goal 53 seconds left on the power play
of manad was well covered gson gets it moves it
tro sliding it across paner scores a seam pass
from Vincent tro and ouri paner as his ninth
goal and 25th point of his season absolutely
lights out to start this season for the Rangers
and look at the puck movement here right through
the seem NOK just can't quite get a stick on that
pass from tro to paner and it's on his stick it's
off his stick and no way vanich can get across as
the Rangers take a one- nothing lead pretty sharp
angle as well Bill uh very accurate shot by paner
who's really feeling it he buried that puck Jack
Hughes want to face off back to the blue line and
now the Devils go to work with Hughes Lazar and
holla out Hughes to the SL rips It Wide of goal
bouncing Puck comes all the way to Hamilton he
throws it to the front it's deflected a lot of
bodies in front of eigor shurkin at the moment
huge retrieves that he shoots his third shot right
here it trickles in but the whistle had blown so
shurkin got it but didn't really catch it clean
and after the whistle that rolled all the way
in it will not be a goal because the whistle had
blown but now the officials come together to talk
about it Ken shot toor [Applause] Durkin well
hard for us to see then he looks behind him he
thought he had that puck Shin did one more left
good angle and there it drops in behind himself
so so the Devils grab the momentum right back
answering the ranger goal poot to the Blue Line
intercepted by Tyler pit and numbers here for the
Rangers Jimmy Bey on the outside two on one Bey
shoots kick save V hard hit there in front on no
oh look it was unfortunate for no cuz that puck
was in his skates he's looking down trou is on
the ice you've got to be aware Schneider shoots
save rebound goes jimmyy the former devil puts it
in pich makes the initial save and Jimmy beey the
former devil and gets enough to give the Rangers
a 2-1 lead that made a good save initially but
that rebound stays right in front and Jimmy vzy
gets loose one more look at it Schneider with the
shot there's the the save and Dey does a really
good job of just staying in front of that net
getting body position and somehow just chipping
that puck pass vanich Luke Hughes is shadowed by
crder now goodro guards in brat works it wide for
Tyler Tooley Devils enter the Zone Tooley forward
for brat comes across poot pulls the [Applause]
trigger Andre panz is First of the Year a power
play [Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music] goal
sometime Devils will take it but it all starts on
the Zone entry so important on the power play and
brat with his speed backs off the ranges gets it
to tley and then there's the spin around pass to
Andre palot right along the ice and it trickles
underneath s to tie this game at two tro is
escorted it off the puck by Marino little job from
the 66 Kevin ball and now the Rangers work it back
L for the air popping free shoots it off F left P
tro played the puck with a high stick brenon Smith
will play it back the other way Guston wedges It
Forward tro giving Chase Smith finishes a hit on
him but it comes to paner he DS and Van comes with
a what a save fake shoot fake shoot maybe pass it
for the for the E tapping look at Keandre Miller
move the other way finds will Coy and vanich kicks
away another detex answered the Bell here in the
second period trouba uncorks a one- timer juicy
rebound off the back wall goes wide up Keandre
Miller nice touch Along by Luke Hughes he and
Colin Miller have seemed to play together very
well in these two games since Miller's return from
injury toley all the way and he got it on and just
STK it makes another what a great move by toi he
had two Rangers on him and he kind of quick little
stick handle to the middle and he's able to get
a pretty good shot off as well Jack Hughes Eric
call and Curtis Lazar out this time paa hits it
hard behind net where Blake Wheeler's first to it
for the Rangers pass was too far out in front as
a bage at so Hughes picks it off he cuts it front
backhander it didn't go it on the one off and
here's Jack Hughes going the back hand and look at
that left Guston back for paner shoots a bouncer
wide of gold an knew it was going wide didn't
leave his crease Sean ther tried to work it up
the boards it's held in paner to the front and V
says no huge save on [Applause] tro he caught him
pretty good in the devil Zone put a perfect pass
on the tape of Curtis Lazar get the Devils into
the offensive end Lazar moves to Hughes back for
Lazar and now douge Hamilton retrieves it he sends
it to Hughes in the corner it rolled off his sck
comes across and the scores he scored four times
against the Rangers in the playoffs and he gives
the Devils the lead tonight Jack Hughes loan it
was Jack Hughes actually losing the puck and that
kind of Bruce just stking off and it came right
out to holla there's the pass from Hamilton Hughes
tries to go to the net but he ends up losing the
handle w isn't that typical though anything Jack
Hughes does seems to turn he was so instrumental
that when he had a terrific Series against the
Rangers he's at a real good start to his season
this year Eric H without is and continues his
fine play thecloud gets it across Tyler to Foley's
turned away and churin stops McLoud on the rebound
what a pass for Michael McLoud to fly in yeah you
and I were looking at the scores around the league
at the intermission and basically every game was
close oh here's a score right off the face off
paner our Tammy paner second today and 10th of the
Season ties the game at three a he is absolutely
deadly and sat there for him but the Devils jumped
by him and look at the release he just wires it it
sits right to the left of the dot as it's kind of
you know a draw off the draw shall I say but panan
finds that Puck and look at that shot short side
over the glove I mean inside of three minutes to
go in the third period Devils with the last four
shots tro find to trailing VY it's Freddy vanage
makes the sa rebound goes oh boy Jimmy VY does it
again and the Rangers lead oh that's a killer big
save by vanich of shurin but stays out there's
the drop pass the save off pitlick and look at
Jimmy Bey stay with it I can't believe he
was able to have the wherewithal he does
a good job of just staying with that [Applause]
pucking Jack Hughes eyeing his options poot one
timer blocked down Luke Hughes had it lost it
wheeler sends it down wheeler scores you got
to be kidding me that's the way it's gone we've
seen Devils pressing here Ranger gold it's when
an empty still plenty of time and and that's
why you just didn't want that empty that or
similar to the one Washington scored as well 8
to 10 days ago where it kind of takes the wind
Devil's build a 32 lead Rangers score the final
three goals in the last 9 minutes and round one of
this rivalry goes New York's way with three more
matchups to come over the course of this season